thank you
hey everybody and welcome to an
accountable wild ride with Stevo I gotta
say that in the two days since we
recorded this podcast
I've thought long and hard about not
putting it out because do I really want
to be that exposed for the things that I
felt compelled to talk about is it even
appropriate to talk about these things
at a public level you know I took
account of where I'm at and how I feel
and what I'm struggling with and uh you
know
it's it is what it is and it's very very
juicy to say the least plus uh man am I
uh just choked up with gratitude for uh
the the part about my team and what my
man Paul Briskey has to say about me as
a boss that uh was really heavy it's
just all like very raw and honest and
let's get into it
ladies and gentlemen me and the guys you
we've got the gorgeous Paul Briskey in
the house hello everybody he's back
Vinnie you imperati that's right Scott
Randolph the the Wild Ride crew and and
Wendy Wendy it's my birthday and I and I
got the blues Man
like I don't I don't like birthdays and
um and and it didn't even happen to my
birthday I was already struggling why
don't you like your birthday I thought
you were upset because we didn't text
you on your birthday
that's my number one thing is that
and there's a lot of things it's not
number one I don't like how I gotta
battle through hundreds of text messages
you know it's just annoying like uh I
had to just bombarded that was my whole
morning it's just oh thank you so much
yeah yeah I really appreciate it yeah I
love you you know for somebody that
loves attention so much that's kind of
like that's surprising it's true yeah
it's true at what age did you start
hating your birthdays 26. he knows 100
26. I remember
uh
25 I was uh working in nightclubs as a
circus clown just getting drunk and
lighting myself on fire doing fire
breathing backflips in this nightclub
and uh I got fired for getting too drunk
but um I got the job on cruise ships I
was started I was celebrating
the next year 26 I'm working in the
circus
and I showed up to work everybody's
there like the whole
uh day I did not tell one person that it
was my birthday because I was bummed
that I was 26.
yeah because that's old like it was it
was older than I cared to be in and uh
and it it was just all downhill from
there
yeah I'm 26. 25 is cool but 26 is a step
too far Amanda's sort of like the end of
like some sort of childhood like no one
says like ah you're young when you're
26. so 25 they sort of say that still
but like they do everybody's everybody's
older than 26 says I you're young you
know now like I'm 49 it's it's a
straight bummer you know like and every
year my birthday just makes me a whole
year older it's this annoying day that
makes you an entire year older when you
don't want to be older and people bug
you with texts all day
and what else but isn't it
is it like a blessing because you didn't
think you're gonna live past 30 anyway
so like you're like dude I'm [__]
plus nine yeah sure sure now
positives too about how
getting older when you go through life
and you
manage to learn from your mistakes and
make appropriate adjustments
it's uh
overcome and and whatever you know like
what ends up happening is you you kind
of get better at the art of living and
and I can't help even though this just
probably sounds douching arrogant but I
genuinely feel that I've gotten
a lot better at living and and when you
get better at life
it really takes a lot of the
the pain out of getting older to get I'm
older but I'm better and I do feel like
like I'm better in a lot of ways so
there's that but why I've been
struggling and then it doesn't have
anything to do with uh with my birthday
this has been going on
um
like
you gonna bring it up I don't know what
you're talking about not like um I don't
I don't know what you're talking about
what I'm talking about is uh this
Dynamic that I've started seeing happen
on my social media when I'm posting on
social media
I want to post like what's gonna Crush
you know I want Solitaire this is going
to be a banger it's going to crush and
I'm posting like
you know like gnarly stunts like jackass
Clips you know like and uh
and and I don't want to post just like
like what's going on with me and where
I'm at you know because like what's
going on with me and where I'm at isn't
like super exciting it's not something
that's gonna totally Crush I just can't
bring myself to post something where I'm
just sitting there you know like you
know like like whatever happens to be
going on I want it to be some kind of
like super high level crazy thing but
then
the like I just see that
that on social media
what I'm posting is just kind of not
representative of who I am you know like
and
um
I was really conflicted about what like
when I when I like twice I've posted me
getting choked unconscious
and uh you know with Michael Bisping in
the Octagon there's something
superficial about that and it got all
this press and I was and I was stoked
but in the back of my mind too I'm like
like
you know like I say no Jeff Tremaine and
Knoxville just hate that so much like uh
what the just seeing it on video they
hate seeing me get choked out they hate
the idea of uh
putting that out there as something
that's cool you know like uh you know
it's just like they think it's dark well
why did you put it out there
because I thought it would crush
and it did not only did it crush it got
picked up by Sports illustrator so many
outlets like the Daily Mail TMZ what you
getting choked out by Mike but not by
Michael Bisping by Michael Bisping yeah
I'm talking about the one where you got
choked out six times right and then
that's the thing is there's like a
couple weeks ago I posted Michael
Bisping but then I'm like I want to
promote the my upcoming UK tour so like
like what footage do I have from the UK
that like that's a tie in you know where
I can and I was like oh dude I'll post
the it's getting choked out six times
and dude I went back and deleted that I
don't know I don't know if you noticed
that I went back and deleted it for two
reasons one I thought
um like it was just like a community
guidelines violation waiting to happen I
mean can we even like touch on how
ridiculous it is that if I post even the
most slightly underdressed
and not sexual but like scantily you
know like anything even remotely
half naked with locks boom like they're
so sensitive about all platforms yeah
it's ridiculous because I see like super
hot chicks wearing almost nothing like
all the time on Instagram yeah I don't
know I don't know maybe it's I'm under a
spotlight I think I know why the reason
why that all the platforms got so
sensitive about sexuality is because uh
of what was in that PornHub documentary
did you guys watch that I did yeah the
the documentary on Netflix look at his
hat they're shitty watching the porn of
documentary Vinny's over there wearing a
Brazzers hat
um yeah the PornHub dog is crazy like
the law used to be that
um like Facebook whatever like the the
none of these platforms were responsible
for what got posted on them because
they're not media platforms they're just
uh like servers you know so they're like
hey man we're just a platform where
people can put stuff up we're not
responsible for what people put up and
that kind of makes sense you know to an
extent but with PornHub they were like
people were uploading like criminal
stuff you know there was like like
non-consensual stuff there was like
stuff with minors you know like and and
and their pornhub's taking the position
hey man we're just a platform where
people upload something are not
responsible for what gets uploaded so
now they can get in trouble now that
that a lot changed not too long ago
where they put their foot down and they
were like yo like you are responsible
for in like particularly around sex
stuff
can you so so like anything remotely
sexy boom take it down but I post being
violently strangled unconscious and
thrown onto my head six times in a row
and it's totally cool with Instagram
yeah but isn't that the problem like it
can be replicated by people I mean it
wasn't the the thing about jackass was
like you guys were doing stuff that
couldn't be replicated
imitate ability
was uh a high concern okay like anything
that's easily imitated it represents
more liability so that's why MTV
couldn't show that uh well if we filmed
like the entire cast being choked out by
Jean LaBelle for the first Jackass movie
and even with the R rating
I don't know that that ever even made it
to the Motion Picture Association for
Ratings purposes I think
Spike Jones Knoxville Tremaine just
thought it was dark and didn't want it
in I don't know no humor in it
yeah maybe probably so what exactly are
you blue about that you've disappointed
Knoxville and Tremaine by posting two
choke out videos no it's not that no I
know what it is and I think it's getting
back to the point of like you're you're
like sitting here working your ass off
to do a post and like I think I don't
know why you're blue about it but I
think the problem is is that you're
trying to when you post on social media
you're trying to go quality over
quantity when what your idea would have
been cool in 2009 2010 like it you know
what I mean it's like a sacred page
where people would go to look at your
[__] but now I feel like everything's
all algorithm based and they're going to
reward you based off quantity not
quality but you're still on the thing
where like I can't post that because
it's not [__] epic but like here's
all these other people that are posting
complete [__] and they're just their
numbers are growing and growing and
growing yeah I mean there's something
there's something to be said for that
like I really I want like I'm just so
sensitive about how Stuff performs you
know like I want it to be like epic I
want it to crush I want it to be rad and
uh and and what I gotta do is just like
relax let like I I really need to just
have like help with it so that I I think
but like you if you look at other people
that are in your same world like they're
just blatantly promoting [__] and like
you don't what you like to do and I
don't know if you've told people this or
what you notice but like you like to
have it behind the the fold so people
could like you're still giving them
entertaining stuff and you're not
pissing anybody off by soliciting and if
you know if they if they're like it's
like you putting a promotion at the end
of a video it's like it's for a certain
amount of people that really want it
there versus up front I want to tell a
story and then use the story to
organically promote something that is
um like tied to the story yeah we did
that really well with the Johnny O
boards we made we told this rad story
about me and Knoxville and you know and
then it went in the best we ever did it
was with Tony Hawk when we told the
story about my history with Tony Hawk
and the double wall ride and then we
sold those prints like I I I really am
super proud that my main Channel isn't a
bunch of like includes paid promotion
where it's like you know I mean that
podcast that are that and that's what
part that's how podcasts work but my
main channel is really like uh you know
it's my it's my baby you know and and I
only well what is the problem because
we're almost there we're almost there
why am I blue but but in pertaining to
social media and like I think you're
you're like five percent you're almost
there yeah what it is
is that
I
I I'm I'm scared
of me and and just the way I am like not
being rad and awesome enough you know
like I wanna like uh I want to maintain
this this uh this Persona like this
image of like just the guy who's the
wildest thing you've ever seen and like
everything's so gnarly and uh and and
I'm just feeling that that's not like
authentic to to who I really am but who
I really am like isn't a Crusher you
know like and so I'm just scared of uh
I'm scared of easing into like who I who
I really am and and that like it's not
gonna engage with as many people and I
just gotta I I just have to like come to
terms with uh who I really am put that
out there and whoever is down with it is
down with it but why is there something
that you like give us an example of
something that you wanted to post but
you thought like no way I can't do that
everything like
what do I want I mean
stories like my meditation streak but is
there something you have in mind that
you're not saying that you're like okay
let me do I have I have a million ideas
on the Whiteboard
you know what not only do I have a
million ideas but I feel empowered to
make them happen and that's just what's
up it's a good thing this episode is
brought to you by better help because
look this was super therapeutic this
whole conversation and if you're
thinking man I really should have this
kind of a situation for myself where I
speak up about what's going on what's
bothering me process it figure out the
way forward then there's no better way
to do that than better help because it's
a whole network of super qualified
licensed therapists you can like plug in
exactly what it is that you want to talk
about what you want to work on and be
matched with somebody who specializes in
that area I use it I love it and it's
really helpful and I'm very happy to be
sending you to betterhelp.com
Stevo for 10 off your first month and
again it's like a network of licensed
professionals and betterhelp.com has
matched like three million people with
therapists and mental health is a thing
so it's
b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p.com slash Devo
betterhelp.com Stevo for 10 off your
first month now let's get back to it
like this uh tour bus that we're in this
piece of [__] RV I'm dying for uh for
you to find an RV dealership that has
the same exact make and model and year
like brand new
so that we can go and do a tour of how
this thing began and then cut to all of
the ridiculous changes that I've made in
here you know like a before and after
Stevo's Tour Bus video and what you're
hesitant of making it because you think
it won't perform well or because people
are going to say like oh he this dude
used to be so rad now he's attacking his
RV more than I don't think it's gonna
perform very well yeah but doesn't that
take the fun out of everything you know
what I mean it's like four I know Paul's
the editor so you're so intimately tied
into this you know you've got to be
understanding where I'm coming but are
you talking about YouTube are you
talking about Instagram everything he's
talking about yeah I mean there's a
number of things you're kind of talking
about here because yes like you're sort
of obsessed with outside validation but
that's also your whole career and your
income is based on outside people being
like that dude rad I want to pay for
what he's done but also for you to post
like something not an insane stunt it's
like nobody looks at the Lego of the
legacy of Stevo any less because you're
not stapling your balls to your leg
today right like you did like it's like
Paul McCartney when he makes an album
not exactly comparing you to Paul
McCartney but like when he makes an
album like it doesn't kill that it's not
Sergeant Pepper but like we don't think
of Paul McCartney any less like he's the
dude that made Sergeant Pepper you know
like right your legacy is intact
I've been okay with putting up videos
that are just like stories and like
don't have to be super gnarly but
there's just like gotta be something
like
high level about it you know I guess I
mean I like that you hold yourself to
some standard I think and especially
like you can compartmentalize these
things YouTube channel we hold a really
high standard for what we put out yeah
and like we don't like to put out
something that's like who wants to watch
20 minutes of like us painting but like
but like an Instagram post like when you
see Bert Kreischer like dude I got doing
a story like I got 10 tickets left come
get it I got one ticket left like you
would never in a million years tell the
world that you attend tickets you
wouldn't do that like what do you use
what do you think about now and here I
am like getting ready to tape this
unbelievable bucket list special in
London England and I haven't even been
able to bring myself to why yeah what's
the reason behind it I don't know I got
it I gotta do it I don't know but why
like what do you think about I just I
just feel like uh it's it's not you know
it's not going to be well received it's
not gonna be like people are stoked but
if I was in like dude if I'm looking on
a story and I'm just like like oh dude
Burt just took a [__] oh [__] Rogan
just posted another part like I'm not
mad at these guys I'm like oh cool like
it's Quick Info if I'm a fan of Steve in
London I'm like oh dude like Steve's in
London and then also like there's so
many different creative ways that you
can go about doing like a promo of a
tour you know what I mean like a bird
look at Matt Rife the one that Matt Rife
just released he did one with like
Ashton Kutcher you know and it was
pretty funny he just like released his
world tour that he's doing like you
could figure out creative ways to
promote [__] but even if it tanks like
it's the whole point of social media to
[__] just feed the beast and if it
takes that that just means they scroll
past it nobody like people don't go to
your Instagram to like see like what's
new what's happening and then they're
like oh I was let down I just that was a
waste of my time it's like I'm scrolling
for hours and hours or sometimes we
won't even push it the Instagram won't
even push the videos it's like idiocracy
they're just like
that's literally I do yeah right yeah I
think what it is there's some way that
when like a story but is uh well
received then it gets prioritized it'll
be like all the way to the left on your
row of Stories on the top like if people
are really engaging with it like it like
Instagram can tell what people are
engaged with they'll push that up and so
something's not engaging then it's just
never gonna ever come into the but
sometimes it's gonna happen sometimes
it's not and it's like if you put a lot
of effort into something and it doesn't
hit then like right and I feel like it
just like it takes the fun out of
everything and when when you take the
phone out of everything like what are we
doing this for right I guess we're yeah
it's it's the paycheck but it's like
what like why did we start doing this in
the first place it's because it's
[__] fun you know so it's like that's
the main thing like you're just
stressing so hard about people like
analytics and I get it because we do
bust our ass to make these videos but at
some point it's like when is this when
is this not fun anymore you know it's so
scary how
like Democratic and like
just
it's red the numbers are right there you
can just see like but if someone didn't
see it then they didn't even know you
posted it in the first place
10 views and it's only 10 people even
know it's them
yeah the million people that didn't see
it are upset with you right well I'm
glad I brought this up thank you guys
for that and and I really you know and I
don't mind being vulnerable and letting
people yeah it's a big step but I'm
actually surprised it's like very
painful for you to talk about I could
see it yeah but it's good because like
it's all [__] like no it doesn't
matter right right yeah and it's a tough
Paradox to live in like we do give a
[__] when they do well and when they do
well like of course that's awesome and
like you should give a [__] about what
you're doing like that's why you're so
successful but also like your art is
your art and you like you have to have
fun doing it like Vinnie said and like
if you love it
put it out you know like I do really
love the the the before and after Tour
Bus video yeah what else do you want out
there uh I mean dude I got a whole
whiteboard is that why we're not doing
it not because we're not busy because
you just don't wanna
there's a lot of there's a ton of stuff
up there and and yeah like like we gotta
you know move forward with with some
content
um and and in in in more of a general
sense not just about what I do or do not
post on social media like um I just
think that uh
like
it's kind of the same idea but
um like my bucket list show is so like
high level like intense you know like
everything is stuff that could not have
happened on jackass because it's just
like somehow gnarlier most of it and I
absolutely got this next tour in me the
gone too far tour even higher level you
know like but
I'm not gonna spend that much time like
you know doing so like I've got a high
level tour and I know my next tour is
going to be super high level like
intense
and uh but otherwise I'm I'm just not
like you know like
I'm just feeling mortal
I think a good thing is is like people
listening in the comments like [__]
you know give Steve some love or give
him a shout out like saying it's not a
big deal you know yeah I think that's I
mean nobody's mad at Mike Tyson for not
fighting right now right nobody's like
you're Mike Tyson you're the [__] like
why aren't you in the ring like yeah
Mike Tyson we love him we love him he
fought he's a champ still the champ like
but he's doing podcasts he's doing like
like you know but he's posting you know
what I mean he's he has somebody else
who's posting [__] for him and I'm
not like [__] Mike Tyson I'm like dude
yes Mike Tyson's the [__] like keep
posting yeah I want to see more
um and I also think sorry to interrupt
you I also think like people enjoy
seeing like every aspect like yeah every
aspect of a celebrity like me personal I
most of the time I like the behind the
scenes [__] more than the actual content
you know what I mean like as far as like
jackass goes I think I like the 0.5s
better sometimes you know and a lot of
people have said that yeah and it's just
like it shows you as a human and I and
like it's the same with the podcast it's
like do more solo podcasts you guys are
great just shooting the [__] you know
it's like because we're we're us okay I
know we're authentic does that have to
be a banger gas we're putting so much
work into it's like this will probably
get decent amount of views
it's crazy how like we get these guests
so many of our guests and people aren't
interested in the guests and and uh it's
probably worth noting that
um we're putting up two podcasts I think
per week for like a three week stretch
yeah I think people will like that but I
do also want to uh I didn't want to
clear up the air but this is something
that we've never talked about on here
but like kind of just been maybe hearsay
or maybe we have but Paul's back in the
studio there have been a lot of people
asking what happened to the gorgeous
Paul Briskey did you guys have it
falling out was it a scandal and we're
gonna let you know exactly what happened
and I'm glad that we're addressing it
and I'm glad that I'm addressing my
health with ag1 I'm telling you man I'm
very ritualistic
meditate yoga ag1 then coffee and you
can jump on this man ag1 is the most
delicious
nutritional supplement to start your day
with and it fills in all the gaps in
your diet it's got everything you need
for gut health like everything man I I
love this stuff man and if you go to
drink
ag1.com
Stevo they will give you an entire year
supply of vitamin D to boost your
immunity and five free travel packs of
this comprehensive and convenient ag1
nutritional supplement jump on this deal
go to drink
ag1.com
yeah dude now let's get back to it
and and I mean pause the studio
technically the editing room Paul's
never left but people always ask where
Paul brisk is and we need to talk about
like you know where you went why what
would the whole thing happen you know
what's going on I think the the question
is where didn't he go yeah
so what's been going on in the world of
the gorgeous Pub people think you got
fired but that's not the case at all you
know I didn't get fired I uh
you know I don't know
I've always sort of tried to keep like
my work life and my personal Pursuits a
little separate right and try to not be
too like
sucked into things that I have a feeling
of autonomy and freedom as I go about
and so like you know I was saying like
oh I'm going to Argentina for two weeks
to record an album and uh I just I kind
of did that a lot we're trying to move
to Phoenix too and I was going to move
to Tucson yeah
so but but yeah I've just been traveling
a lot and recording a lot of music this
year I was in Italy for two weeks and we
were like in this wine cellar of 100
year old house like recording an album
and then I went to Argentina and worked
on it
I just travel a lot and I really value
my autonomy and like what this show
deserves and needs is like someone who's
like here all the time and gonna be in
every episode so it kind of just yeah
but since there wasn't like a big
blowout I think maybe people assume
there was like you [__] blew it
you're fired it was just kind of like
and that's why they're the ones that
like make that known that like dude we
we've never been upset with you or
anything like that if anything
encouraged you to focus on your music
absolutely and so that's why I brought
it up just so people listening know
they're like it's been all love the
whole time with you yeah I love that and
um it's also really impressive how you
figured out too
you figured out how to remotely edit
from anywhere in the world like our
workflow is completely Global while we
were in Australia we're recording
podcasts we're uploading them into the
cloud like Paul's off in Argentina and
pulling them off the cloud onto the
server at the house in Los Angeles and
remotely cutting it together like I mean
it doesn't matter where in the world any
of us are like we're able to to operate
at a high level and that's incredible
and so Paul's been the quarterback of
the media Department like with without
interruption the whole time yeah and and
and and candidly at one point I was like
man like
you know
Paul you're you're traveling so much
like I feel like what we need is
consistency and Paul was like yeah dude
I totally get it man easy
and uh but it's good to have you it's
good thank you it's good to be here and
I'd be lying if I didn't say sometimes I
sort of mourn like that I'd like lost
this consistent gig of being on the show
like I I always told you I love being on
the podcast and like uh
so like sometimes I go like ah man maybe
maybe I blew it maybe I squandered an
opportunity but in the end I'd remind
myself like
I don't know while I was doing it I was
kind of thinking like man I wish I had a
little more freedom to move around so
yeah I'm glad but you're making music
now you have a now working to get your
music that you've been working on yeah
go to that kid is you on Spotify
Instagram everywhere uh we have an album
we made a few years ago that I left for
two weeks to do a few times that album's
called Argentina and uh we have a new
one that's sort of like in the works
right now that we started in Italy and
then worked on more in Argentina but
yeah that kid is you that's my band and
you made an album with your fiance and I
made an album with my fiance Christine
that's called the modern Mystics also on
Spotify and everywhere and you have a
podcast going and I have my own podcast
called the Elk Lodge podcast you can
find us on Spotify YouTube
yeah I appreciate you guys yeah I've
always felt supported in this and like
uh
you know sometimes I'm like man I don't
maybe I made a mistake or maybe I don't
know what I'm doing but
it felt right to me to travel and to do
the things I'm doing and so I've just
always kind of followed my heart and my
gut and
uh
I've always felt selfishly like I want
you all to myself you just work on my
stuff and like I also would never hold
anybody back from pursuing their dreams
and and so like I just as much as I want
you all to myself I've been completely
supportive and encouraging of you doing
but doing whatever you want to do which
is an incredible compliment and like
very appreciated yeah and and the fact
that you've figured out this remote
working so that you know I mean dude I
got people hustle on my team man like
with all this being in different
countries putting the these these videos
and podcasts together like there's time
zones that play and and like I can't
count the times that Paul has stayed up
until like six o'clock in the morning to
get something out again in the time zone
that I'm in yeah yeah yeah like um the
like the the dedication the Loyalty from
every one of you guys and everybody else
on my team is
off the charts yeah yeah I mean while
we're publicly praising people like
you're like the raddest boss I've ever
had and you do such a great like look at
the people around like we're like Bros
you know it's like we all say like I
love you and we mean it and like not a
lot of work environments are that way
feel that way like
there's no like weird HR department or
like corporate structure to this yet
it's like a fully legit like company
that's cranking out incredible stuff so
it's awesome and thank you for that
dinner I'm all choked up so what's going
on in the world is Scott Randolph over
here nothing I'm just uh got my house
and uh I got my dad there right now and
he's have you seen a staying in their
guest room no no he's I have a guy
because it's on a hillside so I have the
seismic operator like trying to figure
out the piling to see if it's safe over
there right now safe what to build more
stuff to build more stuff and to see if
the existing is safe you know to see if
like the pilings isn't that something
that you're supposed to do before you
buy the house yeah
there's some stuff going on in the back
that I wanted to check out because it's
kind of like leaning a little bit and
the guy who came over to build he's like
are you sure this passed and I'm like
yeah what are you talking about he's
like well look at this and I'm like oh
[__] he like puts a ping pong ball on
the floor just rolls I think Cordell
comes over to do my table and he's like
do you have a marble I'm like why he's
like the house looks like it's leaning
over I'm like get the [__] out of here
you know but oh dude
um
couple things we did not uh
scoring touchdown with those fart noises
I blame myself for that I should have
known as an editor that that's nobody
wants that's going to be distracting and
I mean I only wanted just during the one
part where he said it a million times
because he was talking about taking a
[__] with uh well we with with Little
Dicky okay so maybe I mean I I did I
dropped out everything [__] because we
were getting dinged on YouTube and like
we we want this podcast to perform well
and we don't want things working again
like we were censoring it because I
think if they said all the shits were
taken out or something
but if it was he's just it's mellow out
and like we get dinged if you swear too
many times in once yeah yeah and if it
was so if he was actually talking about
[__] like poop I put in a fart sound if
he just said like yeah we were like
hanging out and we were then it was just
dropped out people get pissed yeah and
so I apologize everybody that's on me
what's going on Steve
we brought that up because it's a
problem when you use profanity too much
and then we just threw out like 18
profanity words
can you believe these guys I mean why
were we even talking about that
profanity man it's vulgar but nothing is
more vulgar than a nasty big hairy bush
and that's why I'm so happy to give you
guys this epic deal from
manscaped.com look dudes it's summertime
you're gonna be taking off your your
shirt you're gonna be at the pool you're
maybe even gonna be in bed with some
ladies and there's nothing that grosses
a woman out more than an unkempt
disaster in your nether region so if you
haven't tried it yet then it's time to
try manscaped if you go to
manscaped.com and use the promo code
Stevo you can get 20 off your order plus
free shipping and what do you want to
order let me tell you the weed whacker
that takes care of all the nose hair all
the ear hair it is just worth its weight
and gold thank God for the weed whacker
from manscape and extra thank God for
the weed whacker 2.0 you got the
lawnmower 4.0 with the flashlight on it
so you can see what you're doing
you got all this great stuff at
manscaped.com and it's time to get over
there and use the promo code Stevo for
20 off your order plus free shipping
yeah dude now let's get back to it all
right well we can mute them instead of
do a fart noise but so why what's the
problem if if we do but if we say if we
say the s word like within a certain
matter of like 10 seconds I just know
that that happened the first time we
ever did a solo podcast
uh I was on a rant about the death
penalty and
um I I dropped f-bombs like so many
times in the space in 30 seconds that
the whole
podcast was age restricted on it and you
take whatever
views you're at when a video gets age
restricted and you can just go ahead and
hold on to that number because it's not
going any higher you know like yeah yeah
you have just completely chopped off the
legs of that podcast and it were that
video will not go anywhere I mean it
like
negligible viewership after that and so
like knowing that that is a rule like I
am particularly sensitive when I hear
swear words a lot a lot of times in the
space of a small amount of time because
like I don't want that happening to our
Channel and so during that one story
with Benny Blanco last week
like I I he just kept saying and saying
and I was like okay boom age restriction
we got to do something about this and so
I thought since the story was about him
pooping put a fart noise over the s word
you know like it's not a big deal if you
swear you just can't do it repeatedly a
lot a lot of times in a small space
that's the rule
and uh and no more fart noises easy no
more fart noises yeah I think people
would just mute it you know yeah or just
I mean like I think that it probably
makes sense to tell the guys hey
swearing's fine you just can't do it a
lot a lot of times in a row so it'd be
selective well you know how you can make
it right you can give something away on
the podcast yeah
dude okay now
the the true Die Hard fans of the Wild
Ride podcast will be aware that whenever
there is no guest and it's just me and
the boys
we give stuff away and um it's another
thing that I'm kind of in blue about and
sensitive it's like in one on one hand I
I wanted to stop beating the people over
the head with promotion
I said that a while back and I've really
pretty much honored my word I haven't
been promoting much at all but then I'm
down at the warehouse yesterday and I'm
the FedEx guy comes and says hey you
gotta got any pick up for ground
at our warehouse workers like nope and
I'm like man we've not sold one thing
for the FedEx guy to come pick up not
one not one and then I'm blue about that
so
um every whatever dude I'm not too
tripping but um I love it when we have
these solo podcasts because we just give
stuff away and then that gets you know
the blood flowing in the warehouse
um and I can't believe I'm about to do
this because it's a like a really a
a high priced item these shares what are
we selling these shoes for I think 69 69
bucks why does that sounds about right
and um
are we really gonna just give them away
we have like 300 pairs what's a
wholesale price we bought them for 20
bucks I know that at least 22. yeah 22
bucks a pair and this is the
collaboration
standard and they're literally emailing
America Escape shoes slip-ons slip-ons
like they're they're high quality value
shoes yeah because we had them on we had
them on Amazon and I closed down the one
companies Amazon and then they sent them
all back to us and so that's why we have
it I guess we have 300 pairs is that
right Isaac anyway we have 300 and
something pairs okay so we're gonna take
an L on these shares
we're gonna we're gonna give them away
for
15 bucks a pair
yeah that's less than we paid for them
and you gotta pay for shipping yeah and
shipping's tough when you're on Amazon
there's nothing we can do about that
yeah while you're at the site you can
check out the the come board yeah dude
if I posted the new skyjacking
skateboard on Instagram it would get
community guidelines violation I think
so I I kind of think so
the way it's me uh a cartoon me like
falling out of an airplane blowing a
load yeah
like I mean we we made like uh the load
itself like just comically big to cover
my junk but there's like hairy nuts
creeping out of the bottom it's great
it's a great piece of art
the question is how many people want
that piece of art you know I bought one
did I paid full price I want I love that
because I like collecting boards now yes
yeah I I consider skyjacking this is
probably pretty weird to say but I
consider it the crown jewel of my career
because really yeah because there's so
many layers to it dude like to find the
how many times did you call the the
companies you said hey I got Stevo and
they're all excited I mean can you can
you explain what a crown drool means
because like I would think that at all
your career you know you have the
skyjacking that's for sure it but like
dude the fact that the mountain lions
were [__] pawing at your head like
rings a bell right right or there's
swallowing the Goldfish okay and yeah
those were gnarly things and we will be
putting out a video uh called times we
could have died with Chris Pontius and
it's pretty epic but um
the thing about skyjacking is that I
have have worked
on Live Comedy but like for 13 years now
like 13 years now and
it the journey has been
like I'm not gonna like put put it down
as like oh I was like working it's you
know because it was great but like the
amount of growth the amount of of work
that that got me from where I was when I
started doing Live Comedy to where I am
today it like that's that's like Mount
Everest you know I I asked Paul
um to pull a clip from my first comedy
special as well as a clip for my second
comedy special so that I could promote
the taping of my third comedy special
which is July 14th in London England and
hopefully July 13th if I could bring
myself to promote it and sell enough
tickets to get to that third show but
when Paul pulled a clip from my first
comedy special he showed to me I was
like I can't do it
because there is this palpable
insecurity
where I was just like you know I'm not
particularly mad at the material I
thought the material was fine but I was
just so insecure that I had this thing
where like when I told a joke I would be
like like laughing at my own joke and it
was just this cringy
palpable insecurity just at on display
and I can't do it right is that a fair
assessment
yeah yeah yeah definitely definitely
like it's it's good you grew out of that
and it was kind of like uh yeah it was
like an insecurity like a crutch almost
you were kind of leaning on yeah and and
that first cringy comedy special
uh two in a little bit years later I
taped the gnarly special and there was
unbelievable amounts of growth in those
two years but still man the the gnarly
special like it was better by a lot but
still and now I'm about to tape my third
comedy special The Bucket List and it's
been
more than five and a half years since I
taped gnarly and like the the difference
between the bucket list and gnarly is
going to be like Mount Everest style
growth you know I really believe that
and I'm so profoundly grateful for my
first two comedy specials in that they
serve as milestones for where I was at
at the time
and like I've just come so far so the
reason why I consider skyjacking the
crown jewel is because
like what I've made my thing is all of
my worlds coming together I've got the
Live Comedy I've got the the the stunt
video footage and it's all like merged
into one and like
skyjacking with all of the the comedy of
errors and all of the efforts you know
all of everything that it took to get
like a company to sign off and a guy to
strap himself to my back so that I could
tug one off and blow a load as I fell
out of an airplane like that was the
most insane undertake that's the most
challenging thing we've ever put
together logistically as a production
coordinator that was the biggest
challenge that was the biggest challenge
and then I think that the amount that we
were relying on you to bust the nut oh
the wind that's fair right which you had
to bust them and then and then the
actual like execution of the stunt like
I mean that like that's among the most
it's among the most challenging stunts
I've ever had to quote pull off you know
I'm like and uh and then and then like
capturing it you know like it's not that
easy to like you know blow a load
falling out of an airplane and get it
perfect and just get the money shot it's
like it's a full-on money shot yeah and
like the fact of that it's it's like
it's it's I I think I might genuinely be
the only guy in the world who could make
a video of that and like proudly put it
out like Yep this is what I'm about you
know like say what come come to my show
and watch me jack off yeah like that's
gnarly nobody can get away with that and
like and and
so like it's it's just the most
forbidden the most challenging the most
like from a production point of view
like it's like lightning in a bottle man
well I think that'd be like a porn star
like filming a porn and they're like
okay you have to start [__] at 2 30
and by 239 you have to bust a nut or all
of this works and you're just in your
head thinking like okay all the [__]
two things it's a two minute window not
a nine minute window you know you had to
bust a nut for okay they're like you
start [__] at 2 30. and then you have
to bust a nut at 239 to 240 and you're
just like in your head like okay [__]
I have to bust this nut and then I
matter like yeah I mean it's not it's
gnarly yeah it was gnarly and uh and so
like like that as far as like stunt
footage it's just ridiculous like I love
stuff that goes that crosses boundaries
I love stuff that that uh goes too far
the stuff that I love filming stuff that
no nobody's willing to show because it's
just that crazy you know like it's as
far as like uncensored like gnarly like
uh forbidden footage like that's the top
of the pile and as far as like from a
storytelling Live Comedy perspective
there's so many layers to it there's
just so many like laughs per minute and
the skyjacking bit like as far as strong
stand up and like ultra high level
forbidden stunt footage top of the pile
yeah plus I always love like showing
people something they've never seen
before even though you don't even know
that you needed to see it but like Yeah
just something where like like wow I've
never seen that never seen that ever you
know like I I love doing that and and
dude like how proud am I right I say I'm
the only guy in the world who could pull
it off but like think of it this way
like when you come to my show like you
don't even necessarily think like oh my
God like I'm gonna have to sit here and
watch a guy blow a load like you know
like it's just like oh I'm going because
this Show's gonna be like super crazy
like that's all this crazy stuff and
then I think like when I say at the end
of the show this bit's called skyjacking
I think people realize like oh and then
I tell the story
and it's my job by the time I play that
clip to have people be okay with what
they're about to see and like even your
dad and sister my dad and sister like
all my my I couldn't believe you bucket
and dude that like that's my proudest
work that like on a on a nightly basis
on tour I I take a thousand people on a
journey right up to skyjacking where
they sit there and and joyfully watch me
yeah but yeah that's such a good point
if you just came out and said hey here's
a video of skyjacking you just played it
it would not perform nearly as well like
you've kind of you have built them like
you've built enough trust with them at
that point you've like he's you like
kind of really worked them to where
they're gonna they love it now like
they're they're right joyous yeah I mean
so yeah that that like those are the
reasons why I consider that the the
Crown Jewel you know I think that that
like I I like it takes a a level
of Mastery to make that okay for a
thousand people to joyfully watch
together
masturbatory
yeah and and so whatever that guy that
that's maybe a little much we were
talking about the board right oh yeah to
commemorate this this Crown Jewel
there's the skyjacking skateboard
autographed skyjacking skateboards yeah
there's not that many left too are there
really wait wait come on I mean that are
signed
all right because we send a lot oh
that's right we sent a bunch to the UK
so there really aren't that many and
yeah I didn't even promote them yeah no
they're and they're going they're
they're selling you know that's the
people that go to the website
um I don't know we can even cut this out
but do you want to talk about uh uh that
person that you talk to that lives on
the East Coast that came out of nowhere
after 20 years that reached out on an
email I forwarded it to you
or do you know wow because that's some
juicy little [__] I don't want to put
that on blast
if it's the one I'm thinking about yeah
yeah
I don't know I don't know what you're
talking about we'll tell you I think you
do he doesn't want to do it but do you
we can cut this all out and make you
make it smoother I can say it again but
is that something because
oh I do know why you're talking yeah
okay since since you did that we're not
gonna cut anything out
um I was I was totally shocked and I
don't think I'm worried about scaring
anybody off and and uh if they're not
comfortable with uh with the spotlight
or attention then maybe they want to
rethink it but um I'll just I'm gonna go
out and go a
guy reached out who I haven't seen in 20
years thinking about
getting back into the spotlight in some
fashion and his name is Brandon D
Camilla oh [__] and I spoke to him on
the phone
I mean dude he
we had a great talk you know and it's
just been like how long do you guys talk
for I told him uh I taught him by text I
said dude you're the closest thing to an
actual unicorn that I've ever heard of
yeah and he was like ah yeah it's funny
I mean yeah maybe I am kind of a unicorn
and uh you know he uh does he talk to
anybody
I'm not even sure man I'm not we just
talked about like like like what it
might look like for him to uh
you know
get back into Show Business
yeah now what does he want to do like
what kind of I told him that I thought
that he like out of anybody is would be
the best suited for for performing live
comedy I think that he could just
absolutely kill it for sure not in
comedy clubs like just if you imagine
just like a chunk of his set being
freestyling you know like like uh just
ranting like you know I mean that's what
like I I really consider that Adam out
of anybody who was ever involved with
jackass
he stands alone as the most talented one
of all of us you can take a bunch of us
and put us together and he's more
talented than that just spontaneity or
like uh and I told him this on on the
phone that his ability to
do nothing
like
remarkable you know nothing physical
nothing like dangerous or or
shocking or scandalous or anything but
but to just do very little and make it
Ultra compelling totally hilarious and
just like spin gold out of nothing like
yeah and he hasn't been active on social
media at all right no but I understand
that he has like
filmed like sketches and stuff that he
just never showed anybody wow just for
their own satisfaction that's sick I
think I I want to say that he confirmed
that but I mean I don't know like
he's not like I told him like I think he
could kill it in in Live Comedy and if
he ever wants to come with me on tour
like we could spend time together we
might be doing an East Coast tour
September maybe he wants to show up to
Boston yeah I think we are in the
comment section if you want to see
Brandon in Boston
I think that's a great idea and
um and and like he's uh you know I just
show them like the YouTube and and
creating content I think he'd just
really be well suited to be a content
creator and uh and he said yeah you know
like he wants to wait I even told him I
think it'd be better to wait until like
you've got sort of uh you know a good
amount of stuff to put out and then
we'll get you know we can get you on the
podcast and promote it yeah I mean he'd
be a great podcast guest dude I mean
we've talked about him it's like because
we're like man like trying to find these
unicorns because like we love when it's
somebody that like it's always Brandon
yeah dico is the top of that list always
for sure yeah he he'll Crush have you
heard from uh bam I don't even want to
talk about it but like you haven't these
I don't think I'm on his good side
anymore yeah
I
I yeah I don't know I I like at this
point I don't know anything about him
but more than anybody else yeah yeah
that's a good place to be I mean there's
nothing good about it I wish that he was
doing great and killing it you know but
uh
yeah I don't know and and if he's really
in a treatment center right now
um you know like hopefully you can turn
the corner did you know Lamar Odom had
treatment centers
I I saw that on uh TMZ in like a while
back but he has him he's got three now
he's got three Yeah Yeah well yeah good
for him maybe we can get Lamar Odom on
the podcast uh that'd be cool yeah yeah
I I think that deserves to tangle some
wires at it I uh I don't know if that if
that makes the most sense in the world
um but yeah so this this is gonna air
Thursday I enjoy doing the podcast and
like I didn't do it if Benny Blanco was
the greatest he was so sick in a lot
yeah we went an hour and a half and it
felt like 30 minutes yeah I I do like if
anybody's listening to this still and
didn't see the Benny Blanca podcast find
it let's link it here because because
dude that guy produces music for like
the biggest people out there just as
Bieber Ed Sheeran Ed Sheeran yeah see ya
yeah yeah everybody he's and he's just
the most it's like he like yeah I was
sleeping at Jay-Z and Beyonce's house
like working with Kanye
so you don't hear that every day you
know yeah he's got a red life man I
think next week we might have
back-to-back guest podcast and the
following week we'll have another one of
these solo podcasts but that one's gonna
be
all right you guys
just ambushing me with the most brutal
negative comments
like I I've been you're gonna read the
con you're gonna pick some comments from
the previous ones and like I don't even
want to know yeah I don't even think we
should let him pick I think we picked he
doesn't know until we until we shoot
yeah and and don't don't go easy on me
the point is to get into hurt my
feelings yeah having said that having
said that people are gonna start writing
the gnarliest comments
only from the past like like you sound
like Whoopi Goldberg have you seen that
one yeah that's kind of rad yeah I've
pulled some I think Whoopi Goldberg has
a career yeah she's awesome no I've
pulled a bunch of comments because
comments because Scott said this was
coming good point Vinnie not going
anywhere we won't acknowledge I also
don't even waste your time writing
negative comments to try to get featured
on a video because these comments have
already been curated
and uh did you have enough already I
have a bunch we have two episodes worth
already
but what I also grabbed was like an
interesting comment or like yeah
something that sparked some conversation
I don't think we should do an episode
that's just hurting your feelings and
making you sad and just reading negative
things like that some of that is funny
but like you know right I've been
pulling like and I put on Instagram like
if anyone's got any questions for us
maybe we'll read them soon and like just
fun like it's fun
like hurt my feelings like me twice
about my life yeah
yeah that's the name of the episode
because that's actually the next solo
one where you're like we're gonna be
talking about that right yeah that's an
important like step and just like
processing and like you know this was
therapeutic for me man like um I really
I appreciate you guys I'm glad that I
spent I hope that this podcast resonates
with our audience uh and like dude we I
read the comments like I I like to
engage yeah so so like I want to be more
engaging in the comments like if you
know are the comments
um acknowledging the effort that I've
put in to be more um less of an [__]
yeah
like a conversational etiquette yes
there's definitely some it's like wow
this was great Steve really let the
guests talk on this one
I've seen at least one of those I pulled
no no I mean it's it's all good and I
think I mean maybe you even go through
some of the old podcasts and read them
in real time
and get real live reactions to that I
mean like present me with the cut I
think you guys reading them to me that
or the audience can hear them and and uh
I'll hear them at the same time yeah do
you want to talk about I mean do you
want to wrap this up or do you is there
anything you want to say do you want to
say maybe tease who the next guest is
going to be or anything like that or you
want to do nextcast is for sure Eric
Andre right yep yeah which is awesome
yeah hopefully Eric Andre can steer more
people back to Benny Blanco too because
they're such Pros yeah I actually kind
of regret that we didn't put him out in
the original order intended we still can
no no no like Ben Blanc was out all
right I think we can wrap this can I say
something yeah please do I'm not asking
anybody to buy anything oh boy I just
want people to go check out the new
website yeah your new website yeah I
love it skinny Vinny dot TV you don't
have to buy [__] just go check it out
buy a sticker because we put a lot of
hard work into it yeah buy a sticker
[__] support but yeah skinny Vinny
dot TV skinny vinny.tv and it's worth
mentioning that when you go to stevo.com
it's a whole new website too and we
worked super hard on that yeah happy
birthday dude I love you yeah
yeah
I love the guys Paul and Scott our
birthday present to you was not texting
you
so this week has been a roller coaster
guys and I'll tell you what I did
immediately after this uh podcast
wrapped up I went over to a place called
foamart and and and uh traced the
outline of the window of the podcast van
and got a piece of foam then I went over
to Home Depot to get a new air
conditioner so that because it's summer
man it's gonna be hot so like with the
foam and I figured then I built this
foam capsule to go over the top of the
air conditioner to run the hose through
the window and cool down the van and I
just got such a big kick out of it made
a video of it and gosh dang darn it I'm
posting that video it's me building a
foam top to an air conditioner and I'm
gonna post it because I think that's
cool but it should be in the stories
just the stories
whatever in any case I'm a work in
progress over here guys and uh I do want
to end with this
um but by no means are any like negative
comments getting featured in anything
but if you do have any like actual
questions
um we will be looking in this comment
section for interesting questions to
spark discussion on Future No guest Wild
Ride episodes let us know if you like
the No guest episodes man because
um like I want to give you guys what you
want because I love you especially the
ones who stick around at the very end so
thank you and I hope your weeks [__]
awesome